it just appears to me there's a smack of
desperation about what the prime
minister is doing on legal migration
this week everyone's obviously aware
he's looking at the reform polling
numbers terrified of what Nigel farage
might do when he comes back from the
jungle has realized that his preferred
thinking was that everyone really cared
about the boats but people weren't that
bothered about legal immigration so long
as quotes that it there was this control
in theory well I think he's found out
from private polling that's not the case
he's running to catch up but he looks
like rather than instigating something
because he believes in it he's just
being pushed around he's on the back
foot and even Kier starma now seems to
have outflanked him as a migration
skeptic which is sort of hilarious
position for suak to have got himself
into